la pharmacienne Louise papillon Ferland
a réduit la médication de sa patiente
Louise Thériault qui est âgé de 93 ans
bonjour Alors on est ici aujourd'hui en
fait on voulait peut-être faire un suivi
au niveau de vos médicaments mais
comment allez-vous moi je vomir c'est
plus qu'on trouve puis
les médicaments sont
aussi puis j'ai ma fille qui
m'aide beaucoup en tant que prochain
Dante madame Palmieri a conduit bon
nombre de fois sa mère à l'hôpital sa
pression artérielle était souvent trop
élevée
vingtaine de
pilules par jour en plus de deux fois se
piquer matin soir alors c'est beaucoup
de médication
c'est après avoir reçu une demande de
révision de médicaments de la part du
géria de Madame theriot que la
pharmacienne a révisé la médication de
sa patiente est-ce qu'elle est troubles
d'équilibre est-ce que des problèmes au
niveau de la nutrition au niveau de la
mémoire et puis ensuite c'est vraiment
d'aller faire la révision de la
méditation au complet et selon le
gériatre walking Guyenne le problème ce
n'est pas la quantité mais plutôt la
combinaison de médicaments qui peut être
problématique avec le temps quand on
vieillit notre système change notre sont
moins efficaces on a un peu plus de gras
moins de muscles notre foie très les
médicaments moins rapidement et il y a
des médicaments qui dans ces contextes
de changement de notre corps en plus
d'effets secondaires que des faits
bénéfiques alors que 40% des CHU CLD au
Québec n'ont pas de pharmacien attitré
il apparaît difficile pour l'instant de
réviser les prescriptions de médicaments
de l'ensemble des ennemis qui habitent
c'est pas une rencontre rapide en
cabinet 10 minutes qui permet de faire
sourire ça peut prendre 4 5 heures dans
tous les cas québé qui semble avoir la
ferme intention de remédier à la
situation avec l'embauche de 200
pharmaciens dans les CHSLD publics et
privés conventionnés d'ici 2025 ici
Gabriel prout radio -Canada Montréal